Le Titanic s'appelait le navire des rêves
et c'était vraiment le prendre pour voir
mr.  Murdock,
je n'ai jamais douté une seconde que le
Titanic avait raison pour la 3d, la question
était de savoir quand le faire et j'ai toujours pensé
que le centenaire du vrai naufrage
serait une opportunité parfaite, vous savez,
je suis un peu connaisseur de la 3d, nous
J'ai commencé à fabriquer des appareils photo numériques 3D il y a 12 ans, j'ai donc tourné énormément de
3D et je suis très pointilleux à ce sujet et donc si
je dois faire une conversion, il doit être à la
hauteur de ces normes, je voulais que ce soit
le  équivalent à ce à quoi cela aurait
ressemblé si nous l'avions réellement tourné
en 3d, nous avons commencé par la restauration
car nous n'avons jamais eu de véritable
maître numérique de Titanic, nous l'avons donc nettoyé
et rendu aussi vierge que possible
avant même  commencé le
processus de conversion 3d nous avons testé un certain nombre d'
entreprises différentes pour nous prouver que nous
pouvions avoir la qualité que nous voulions dans la
présentation nous voulions établir l'étalon
-or de la conversion alors nous l'avons
amené au sol avec notre artiste et
nous  lui a montré ce que la technologie c  an do
Titanic est mon bébé, alors bien sûr, je vais
retrousser mes manches et m'impliquer dans
chaque étape de ce processus, chaque image
est considérée comme une œuvre d'art et chaque
image a une vision créative de la façon dont
nous allons ajouter  la profondeur de cette image
convertir un film en 3d est littéralement 300
artistes informatiques dans ce cas travaillant
pendant plus d'un an pour décrire chaque sujet
chaque objet chaque partie du visage de tout le monde
et le mettre sur ses
plans de profondeur corrects, puis nettoyer tout pour que
vous  ne sais pas qu'une opération délicate
a été effectuée,
vous essayez de l'amener à l'endroit où
c'est ainsi qu'un public croirait qu'il
verrait le monde 3 B n'est pas un monde
sortant d'une fenêtre, c'est une fenêtre
sur un monde I '  Je suis fermement convaincu que la 3D
améliore non seulement les grandes vues
et les actions spectaculaires, mais qu'elle améliore également les
petites interactions humaines. Les moments intimes
sont très puissants en 3D car vous avez l'impression
d'être vraiment là et vous vous sentez
physiquement présent avec les personnages
et som  ecomment c'est plus émotionnellement
impliquant, vous savez qu'une chose que Titanic
vous montre plus que tout, c'est à quel
point le drame peut fonctionner et vous avez l'impression
d'être sur le bateau pour
ramener le Titanic consiste à offrir
Titanic à un groupe de cinéphiles qui n'avaient
pas pu  le voir sur grand écran,
c'est juste pour revoir le film
sur grand écran, cela ramène ces
émotions de l'avoir regardé avant
de mettre la 3d en plus et c'est
tellement magnifique et luxuriant et vous vous sentez comme
vous '  êtes juste là dans ces espaces incroyables à
bord du navire ou vous avez raison,
ils traversent le Jeopardy que
Jack et Rose traversent et cela le
propulse vraiment à un tout autre niveau,
mais ce navire accoste, je descends avec
vous
Je ne te lâcherai jamais